so I developed the MOOC visualizing
Japan home which is MITx Harvard X joint
project with John Dawa of MIT and II
Gordon of Harvard and also Jennifer
Weisenfeld of Duke I incorporated the
MOOC material into my residential class
in 2014 and he changed everything
it changed literally everything and I
continue to use it right up until my
last offering which was fall of 2016
before 2014 it was a very traditional
class with lectures powerpoints a little
bit of student discussion what I
incorporated the MOOC material in 2014 I
didn't anticipate any major changes I
simply said why don't you look at these
video lectures we just produced see what
you think think about them and what I
realized right away was that students
would come into class and they would
have a lot of knowledge which was not
the case before so I would ask you know
so when did Perry come to Japan 1853
when did Meiji era begin 1868 why did it
begin - you know I had a whole set of
powerpoints which I had created from
years of teaching I did not show a
single PowerPoint I for 70 minutes I
just asked them questions just to see if
I can find something that they didn't
know they knew the whole thing and I
said gee this is this is different and
without realizing it without I didn't
even know what a flipped class was I
just did a flipped class I did not
lecture for a single minute it was just
question answer discussion
in opposing the deeper questions for
students to discuss and I was absolutely
absolutely stunned that just in this one
class the way I teach changed
fundamentally so by having flipped the
class one very concrete thing that came
out of it this is MIT so one of the
students was actually getting some data
on this so there were a couple times
when I had a traditional lecture class
because I had to need to do something
and this student are timely and she
found that I was speaking eighty percent
students twenty percent which is for a
traditional lecture class that's not bad
and then she told me that and said well
look why don't you do the same thing
when we do the discussion so she did
that and she found that it was 50/50 it
quantitatively it's just completely
different completely different remember
we had a bunch of visitors from Japan
second week of the class and I was doing
the you know interactive style and they
came up to me and said so how many
months have you been teaching this class
two weeks it's quite remarkable I mean
just a sheer amount of knowledge the
students gain from this new way of
teaching is just it's income you cannot
compare to in the previous you know we
like to lecture we all write the lecture
and I miss lecturing a lot of faculty
members who class tell me this you know
so in their so quiet moment in the
corner of their room you know they
whisper I'm a spectrum but we all know
that this flipping class makes it so
much more effective
what's really important is to have good
material for students to study ahead of
class and I strongly recommend video
video is a very rich source of knowledge
and if you combine that with reading
you'll be amazed at how much students
bring into into class and as one of my
colleagues Rona Gibson who has flipped
or materials class has said the reason
why flipped class is so effective is the
students touch the same material several
times once when they are viewing it
before coming to class in second time
when are we discussing discussing it in
third time when they do a pset based on
them that's why it's so effective yeah I
think lecturing is going to go the way
side of blackboard